un renouvellement révolutionnaire du
communisme en rda dernière promesse en
date d'egon krenz et le chef de l'état
est-allemand jour après jour les
réformateurs gagne du terrain l'un
d'entre eux hans modrow fight est nommé
premier ministre des réformateurs encore
qui font une entrée spectaculaire une
entrée en force au sein d'un politburo
profondément remanié une constante en
tout cas c'est la pression de la rue une
pression de la rue qui se maintient ce
soir encore des milliers d'allemands de
l'est manifester dans les
correspondances de notre envoyé spécial
en rda hélène risacher
reportage sur la journée historique
encore unis que vient de vivre la rda le
parti communiste est allemand prend un
coup de jeune et joue l'ouverture
quelques heures seulement après la
démission de son bureau politique du
comité central du parti s'est doté d'une
nouvelle équipe rajeunie le nouveau
bureau politique est formée selon les
mots mêmes du numéro un gone crainte de
gens qui ont de l'énergie et de la
détermination pour restaurer la
confiance perdue dans le pouvoir car le
parti traverse sa plus grave crise de
son existence cet après midi devant le
siège même du comité central
manifestation de quelque 10 personnes
membres du parti ils sont venus écouter
les dirigeants du pc et les militants de
base faire un tribut la crise de
lignières ce qui passait et proposer un
renouveau du pc les discours les plus
applaudis sont les plus virulents les
manifestants scandent le nom des gones
crainte de numéro un du pays et à la
réunion du comité central mais les
filles par sortir seul moyen d'amener le
calme il réaffirme à la tribune sa
volonté de changement enthousiasme de la
foule mais conseille à la foule de lire
son discours dans la presse demain
frustrée elle siffle après
l'intervention des gones craignent la
foule s'est dispersée rapidement alors
qu'à quelques mètres de là le chef du pc
de berlin est une perche à bosse qui
annonce d'un seul coup la possibilité d'
élections vraiment libres dans le pays
et il ajoute des contacts sont pris avec
les organisations d'opposition comme le
nouveau forum qui va être légalisés
inimaginable il ya seulement trois
semaines en rda le parti communiste
est-allemand multiplie ainsi les coûts
politiques il joue son bateau la crainte
de l'ordre établi et du pouvoir n'existe
plus dans la population elle exige la
démocratie le numéro un google trend
sait que son avenir et celui du parti
dépendent des réformes que décidera le
comité central d'ici vendredi berlin est
hélène risacher pour soir 3